let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 listen for your area code remember
that the way the system works now you'll
be able to hear me talking to other
callers so you got to pay close
attention for when I say your area code
and we will start with our caller from
the 404 area code caller from 404 who's
that what's on your mind today
hey David this is Jeff from Atlanta
again how are you good what's going on
not much how much I was gonna call ask
you about Trump Russia today but after
this week of Democrats I just Democrats
behavior I thought and asked your
opinion about what you think of the
caving of Democrats these this past week
and where we're going from there yeah I
mean my big-picture view I believe that
these government shutdowns are basically
political theater I don't mean that they
don't have real impacts but as we've
talked about the overwhelming majority I
think Pat said something like 90% of
government continues to function even
during a government shutdown so I think
that these are basically the Democrats I
think lost in terms of the PR because
they did basically cave without really
getting anything they got this vague
promise I will do something on Daka at
some point soon in the future so I think
Democrats Mis played it but I think the
entire concept of the government
shutdown is like a bipartisan disservice
to the American voter taxpayer citizen
resident whatever I think it's horrible
do you think it's just more of a
political football than anything else
yes but that doesn't mean the Democrats
didn't miss play it I do believe that
they ended up basically that they
initially held out and it made sense
because Republicans that you've got the
majority everywhere you control the
House Senate and White House but you've
got to at least work with Democrats and
they didn't and Democrats said well then
we're not going to go along but then
Democrats relented without having
achieved anything and of course they
said listen we're just doing the right
thing because we got to get government
back up and running but the truth is if
it was worth stopping government over
that then it might have been worth
keeping it going a little bit longer
trying to get something out of it if
that makes sense Jeff absolutely I was
just are these the kind of Democrats you
want to support in the future because
honestly I think they're spineless and
they they aren't standing up for what
our values are you know they're they're
caving to get they've given so much to
her hash tag resistant they've given
Donald Trump everything he wants along
with this new FISA agreement giving him
more of the NSA and and a warrantless
tapping powers yeah to do bug America
mean the eighteen Democrats voted for
this stuff yeah I don't want this is
what really upsets me and and this point
is sort of ties into my whole Russia
narratives that they use that to
distract people wow these things happen
while Democrats cave while they pretend
to be part of the resistance but in
reality they're really just supporting
the the same policies Obama supported
yeah I mean they listen there's there's
there's a lot there there's some of that
but also there's also fake scandals you
in the same way that you can say Russia
is being used to distract from other
things other things are also about ya
know I gotta yeah I know
I know he's guilty of corruption with
Russia I just I just get disgusting
witness custody that's all the coverage
is Russia Russia as opposed to like the
real the tax bill that just passed a few
months ago a month ago how bad it is the
media did a poor job of doing that
so that's yep it's the Democrats that I
don't support so anyway well thank you
for taking my calls
all right thanks Jeff appreciate it and
always great to hear from Jeff and a lot
of good points there